Brad Pitt offers his thoughts on Donald  Trump supporters and looks good while  doing it the allied actor graces the  fall men's fashion cover of T magazine  and during the interview gave his  thoughts on brexit saying quote man I  never thought that would happen  same way I can't bring myself to think  that Trump will be in charge I'd be more  to the left but I I pay attention I'm  interested in what they have to say I  think there's some valid arguments and  and and most time I disagree that's what  Brad told et during the election debates  in 2012 and now he's trying to  understand where Trump supporters are  coming from I want to do something  that's really gonna put us back on the  right course and make America great  again a trump supporter is fighting  against just about everything what does  he even mean take our country back  would someone please explain that to me  where'd it go